let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
speaking of debates it uh if we must
continue speaking of debates
the daily wire reports the second
presidential debate between president
donald trump and democratic nominee joe
biden will take place virtually
with both candidates in separate
locations the commission on presidential
debates announced on thursday
the commission announced the new form
after trump tested positive chronovirus
last week
trump responded to the news minutes
later asserting he would not do a
virtual debate
um according to a statement from the
commission the second presidential
debate will take the form of a town
meeting in which the candidates would
participate from separate remote
locations the town meeting participants
and the moderator steve scully
will be located at the adrian arsht
center for the performing arts
the white house pool will provide
coverage of the second presidential
debate okay
but trump says on fox business he was he
was asked about it and he said i'm not
going to do a virtual debate
i you know i think this is a mistake
personally i'm probably going to be in
the minority
among conservatives i don't know i'm not
really sure if i will be or not but i
think trump needs to do the debate
he's down in the polls the last debate
didn't go very well
for him you know he he has more to gain
from another debate than than biden does
um so this the strategy of not doing it
i don't i don't really see you know you
know i
and this has been my point i think it's
a little bit of a little bit of maybe
tough love tough talk for uh some
conservatives and some trump supporters
who are whistling past the graveyard a
little bit
and we see all these polls coming out
and almost all of them look bad for
trump to varying degrees
um and but what we hear of course is
that well
you know you can't trust the polls they
were wrong in 2016.
2016. remember 2016. this is how it was
in 2016. everybody said trump would get
killed in 2016. he didn't 2016 2016.
yeah i know that was 2016 though it's
not 2020.
you're never gonna win a campaign by
pretending that it's four years ago
especially when so much has happened in
the
in the uh intervening years and
especially when there are so
there are a lot of obvious differences
here number one he's not running against
hillary clinton anymore that was a big
advantage he had
being that she still is the least
likable person on planet earth she was
also under investigation by the fbi at
the time
so i mean he he he couldn't have asked
for a better opponent
so he doesn't have that no there are a
lot of weaknesses to joe biden but he's
not
hillary clinton he's not just this
viscerally
detestable guy you might not like him i
don't like him
but i'm talking about how he's perceived
in the public it's not like hillary
clinton
uh so he doesn't have that going for him
he's not he's not a novelty act anymore
he's the incumbent
and then you add in you know the economy
coronavirus
riots everything some of that cuts for
him some of it against him
but it's just it's the point is it's an
entirely different situation and so if
you're if you're telling yourself ah
it'll be fine because remember 2016
i think we're making a big mistake and
remember this is the mistake
that a lot of hillary clinton supporters
made
in 2016 it's because they were so
confident
now i'm gonna have a fly problem it's
gonna be flying up but this is a good
thing is if i have a fly on my head you
won't be able to see it cause i've got
that's pence's problem he had white hair
so you could see the fly anyway
um but hillary clinton supporters
were so confident that i think many of
them didn't show up because they figured
that they were going to win
and um i think that's that's a
foolhardy confidence you don't want to
have so
trump needs to really try to win if he
doesn't try he's not going to
and i think that includes doing the
debate now that said
objecting to a virtual debate i think
doesn't make a lot of sense
but i do think there there are other
reasons
other good reasons to object to a debate
uh and
one thing that trump could do is take
issue with the moderator i mean i think
that
the republicans in general forget about
format
virtual or not when it comes to the
moderators
republicans in general should be putting
their foot down and saying we are not
going to do any more debates
period at all until you give us a
moderator
who is not an unofficial member of my
opponent's campaign
it's not an unreasonable demand the
moderator last night i thought was even
worse than chris wells
absolute embarrassment a lot of examples
of bias the most biased thing we got
though
from the moderator last night was when
she was talking about the brianna taylor
case i don't know if you picked up on
this
she referred to the police officers
breaking in to briana taylor's apartment
they were serving a legal warrant and
she categorized that as a break-in just
an absurdly
biased framing and in false framing for
the question but that's what you get
from these moderators okay
number two well it's uh groundhog's day
all over again more rioting this time in
wauwatosa a city in wisconsin here's
just one short clip of the rioting watch
this
[Music]
the reason for the riot is the da's
decision not to charge the officer with
a crime in the shooting of alvin cole
cole
17 year old black male was shot by
officer joseph mensah at a shopping mall
the d.a says that cole was armed with a
stolen pistol
he had flashed it at somebody during an
argument and then he pulled the gun
on the cops he actually fired the gun he
hit himself apparently in the process
but
uh he pulled a gun and fired it and
that's when he got shot
the officer who shot him by the way is
black
okay he's a black man
but this somehow so you a black police
officer
uh shooting an armed
person who pulled a gun on him that
somehow is racist
police brutality a black police officer
shooting a guy who points a gun at him
is a racist police brutality well sure
why not because
none of these words have any meaning
anymore they have just no meaning you
can use them however you like
the words like racist police brutality
they should have meaning
in reality they have meaning but the way
they're used there's no meaning you just
throw them out it doesn't matter if it
applies or not
um i'll have more to say about this case
probably tomorrow so we'll get back to
it
number three from reuters says netflix
incorporated is facing a criminal charge
in a texas county for promoting
lewd visuals of a child in the french
film cuties according to a statement
from tyler county's district attorney
the document filed on september 23 said
netflix promoted material in the film
that depicts lewd exhibition of the
public
of the rather of the pubic area of a
clothed or partially clothed child
who was younger than 18 years of age
which appeals to the
prurient interests in sex
netflix said in a statement that cuties
is a social commentary against the
sexualization of young children
discharges without merit and we stand by
the film
so this is a government enforcing basic
standards of decency
i'm all for it i love it i think it's a
great thing i'm glad the government's
doing it
i wish more uh local governments would
do this
but i do think it's in and this is this
has been the reaction i've noticed from
i haven't seen any conservative
objectivists this this
most conservatives anyway are
celebrating this and saying good
um the the interesting thing though is i
i can remember
about a year ago when we were talking
about laws related to pornography
some of us were making the case that the
government should enforce basic
standards of decency especially to
protect children and a whole lot of
conservatives had a big problem with
that
if there's been a change in heart that's
great maybe we're starting to realize
that yeah protecting children
um that sort of thing that the
government does have a role there
all right number four um big news here
if i can find it
oh here's the big news
apple is turning the mask emoji frown
upside down in an upcoming update to the
ios this according to cnn
the mask emoji has typically been used
to represent someone who is in the
medical field or is sick
however with mass becoming more
ubiquitous due to the pandemic
apple is changing the emojis look in the
upcoming why am i even reading this
anyway they've got more mask emojis
coming okay that's all
i only bring this up just just because
it's it's further proof i think of my
point
that emojis are stupid that's all
there you go evidence number five
finally oklahoma county jail employee
employees gregory cornell butler jr and
christian charles miles have been
charged with cruel
cruelty and conspiracy for handcuffing
inmates and forcing them to listen to
baby shark
on repeat for hours
now as a parent i'm
thrilled to find out that i can actually
have my children prosecuted for
committing similar crimes against me
i think many parents have have dealt
with this now granted my kids never
really got into the baby shark craze
thank god for me it's been the book
we're going on a bear hunt that is our
baby shark
that is the thing that is that is heard
that it reverberates through our
household at all hours of the day
all of my kids have been obsessed with
this with this book um they like to have
the book read to them
they like to watch videos of other
people reading the book
they like to listen to musical
renditions of her going on a bear hunt
it is it is torturous it has
ruined my life
we're going on a bear hunt we're gonna
catch a big one
what a beautiful day we're not scared
uh oh grass long wavy grass we can't go
over it we can't go under it got to go
through it swishy swashy swishy swashy
and on and on and on that's how the book
goes repeating itself
for pages and pages and the book doesn't
even make sense first of all
the onomatopeias that it uses are
completely arbitrary
swishy swashy for grass what kind of
grass is swishy swashy
and the plot is even worse the plot is
this family
mom dad kids young kids walking through
the woods
trying to catch a bear what what sort of
neglectful psychotic parent
brings their kids into the woods to
catch a bear a big bear it's even
specified
this this but this is this book is
basically
an account of an attempted
murder-suicide that's how that's how
disturbing it is it might as well be
we're gonna go drown ourselves yay
it really is that and you know it's
brainwashed my kids on top of it
every time we're in the woods now we go
for a hike or something every time my
son
is is saying let's go on a bear hunt and
i say oh
you're going to hunt for a bear huh with
what we don't even have a hunting rifle
what are you going to use a stick
the kid's going to get himself mauled
and you know what it's going to be the
fault of this book
so we all have every parent has
something like that that tortures them
it's different for all of us um
okay hopefully one day our kids will be
brought to justice for
inflicting this psychological torture on
us well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content